schrödingers katze ist tot und lebendig
indem gedankenexperiment hatte der
wissenschaftler erwin schrödinger die
paradoxen eigenschaften der
quantenphysik formuliert denn
schrödingers katze stirbt durch den
radioaktiven zerfall eines atoms und der
atome laut konnten physik erst durch die
beobachtung überhaupt einen zustand
annehmen bis diese katze in einer
verschlossenen box zusammen mit dem atom
beides tot und lebendig und dieses
experiment wurde jetzt real mit einem
laserstrahl umgesetzt ich sage nur
achtung brain fakt weltkrieg substanzen
fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen schon jetzt werden kranken
computer verbunden und es ermöglicht uns
botschaften abhörsicher über große
distanzen zu verschicken
aber es wird noch besser bedeutend dafür
könnten sogenannte katzen zustände seien
und das lässt sich erklären mit dem
gedanken experiment von erwin
schrödinger zur quantenphysik aus dem
jahr 1935 in der die katze gleichzeitig
tot und lebendig ist eine katze ist
gemeinsam mit einer kleinen menge an
radioaktiver substanzen einer kiste
eingesperrt die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
eines der radioaktiven atome in der
nächsten stunde zerfällt oder nicht ist
gleich groß
ein detektor ist über der küste
installiert und registriert ob ein atom
seinen zustand ändert falls radioaktives
material zerfällt sorgt ein geigerzähler
dafür dass ein hammer einen behälter mit
gift zerstört das würde dann den tod des
tieres bedeuten so weit so klar
doch schuldiger stellte auch fest dass
von außen betrachtet ja gar nicht klar
ist ob ein atom zerfallen ist oder nicht
zumindest solange die kiste verschlossen
ist bis jemand die box öffnet und
nachschaut verharrt der atomkern also in
der überlagerung der beiden zustände
zerfallen und nicht zerfallen
dabei hängt das leben der katze doch
gerade von diesem zerfall des atoms ab
in seinem gedankenexperiment befindet
sich die katze also in einer art
zwischenzustand in der dem sie
gleichzeitig tot und lebendig ist wenn
die quantenphysik sagt dass der zustand
erst dann eindeutig festgelegt ist wenn
die umwelt mit dem system interagiert
wenn also gemessen wird dazu der
physiker gerhard
aber er ist direktor am max planck
institut für quantenoptik nach erwin
schrödingers idee kann ein mikroskopisch
teilchen wie zb ein atom sich
gleichzeitig in zwei unterschiedlichen
zuständen befinden
man spricht dann von überlagerung wenn
es zudem mit einem makroskopischen
objekt verschränkt wird kann es seine
überlagerung auch an dieses weitergeben
daraus ergibt sich das beispiel von
einer katze die in abhängigkeit vom
zerfall eines radioaktiven atome
zugleich lebendig und tod sein kann
eine vorstellung die jeglicher
alltagserfahrung widerspricht doch im
mikrokosmos ist eine solche überlagerung
von zuständen gar nicht so ungewöhnlich
dazu ein beispiel ein atom kann sich
gleichzeitig nach links und nach rechts
drehen erst wenn dazu eine messung
durchgeführt wird entscheidet sich
welche der möglichkeiten realität wird
ähnlich beim doppel spalt experimentiert
kann ein photon beispielsweise sowohl
den einen als auch den anderen spalt
durchdringen erst durch die messung
selbst wird der weg des photons
festgelegt total ver rückt das ziel von
forschungsteams weltweit ist es das
philosophische gedanken experiment von
schleuniger im labor zu realisieren und
dabei diese quantenmechanisch
überlagerten katzen zustände
herzustellen und nachzuweisen
dafür gibt es verschiedene modelle
allerdings ohne kratzen denn es geht ja
viel mehr um die überlagerung zustände
von wandten objekten die kiste in der
die katze eingesperrt ist besteht bei
dem experiment des münchner
forschungsteams aus einem hohlraum mit
zwei gewölbten spiegel in einem
sogenannten optischen resonator darin
ließen die wissenschaftlerin
wissenschaftler ein rubidium atomen
schweben seine quantenzustände bringen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in einem
überlagerungszustand das forschungsteam
aus münchen nutzte ein modell bei dem
die katze durch die photonen eines
laserpuls dargestellt wird dieser wird
durch die wechselwirkung mit dem
resonators mit dem atom verschränkt
somit übernimmt das laserlicht die
überlagerung eigenschaften des atoms
dazu stefan welte einer der beteiligten
forscher
es ist uns gelungen fliegende optische
katzen zustände herzustellen und zu
zeigen dass sie den vorhersagen
mechanik entsprechen wir konnten somit
beweisen dass unsere methode
funktioniert und weiterhin untersuchen
welche parameter entscheidend sind
und nicht nur das denn das besondere bei
diesem experiment ist zum einen dass
sich die art der zustände gezielt
steuern lässt heißt also konkret dass
beliebig viele zustände mit
unterschiedlichen phasen der
überlagerung hergestellt werden können
zudem kann die katze den kasten
verlassen und bleibt trotzdem im
überlagerungszustand die photonen
behalten nämlich ihren
überlagerungszustand selbst wenn sie
durch eine glasfaser gesendet werden
die optischen katzen zustände können
somit über weite distanzen aufrecht
erhalten werden weil die katzen in
diesem system also mobil sind quasi
fliegen gelernt haben ist das
forschungsteam mehr als optimistisch
dass ihr experiment bei der entwicklung
und beim betrieb futuristischer konnten
netzwerke nützlich sein wird denn diese
fliegenden optischen katzen könnten in
zukunft verwendet werden um quanten
informationen zu kodieren und zu
übertragen dazu gerhard rempe schuldig
als katze war ursprünglich in eine kiste
eingesperrt um wechselwirkungen mit der
umgebung auszuschließen optische katzen
zustände wie wir sie realisiert haben
sind nicht in eine kiste eingesperrt
sondern fliegen frei in zukunft möchten
wir mit dieser technologie ganze quante
netzwerke aufbauen
bei der fliegende optische katzen
informationen übertragen
bleiben wir bei katzen tierversuche
werden nämlich demnächst überflüssig die
video premiere auf unserem englischen
kanal also das video gibt es hier noch
nicht während auf animal testing auf
jeden fall extrem interessant hier
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran